- Remington is being sued
because its guns were used
in the Sandy Hook massacre from years ago.
And as part of this ongoing litigation,
the plaintiffs claim that Remington
is trying to bury them in
paperwork in discovery.
As you know, discovery is the process
where one party gets more
information from another,
and the plaintiffs are claiming
that Remington has provided
tens of thousands of
GIFs, memes, and videos
completely unrelated to anything
in response to their discovery requests,
like Santa Claus, this
couple, and filet minion.
Now, that's not abnormal,
often you'll have a request
that's broad in discovery
and that discovery request
will include a whole bunch of stuff
and the other side will try
and bury you in paperwork
and provide you everything
that is responsive to that request.
But what is unusual, and
is particularly telling,
is that Remington has
only provided 2,300 emails
over several years of communication.
That's not how corporations work,
there are tons and tons
of more responsive emails
and corporate documents,
it just means that Remington
hasn't provided them.
So it looks like because motion to compel
probably holds some water
and we're going to see Remington in court.